foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight Piers Morgan uncensive but not
with peers with me Rosanna Lockwood
we've got Donald Trump becoming a
coming the former U.S president to be
charged with a crime but will this harm
his bid to re-enter the White House or
quite the opposite we'll be debating
that the BBC has been slammed for sexing
up its new period drama Great
Expectations now coming with added sex
drugs and rock and roll why do modern
writers keep messing with the classics
though can't they leave the likes of
Dickens Dahl and Agatha Christie well
alone
plus those pesky vegan fun police
they're at it again they've shut down a
goat's cuddling event in America would
you believe it they say it's animal
cruelty the farmers say no goats are
being harmed so what's the problem
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Rosanna Lockwood
good evening welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored with me Rosanna Lockwood just
thought you thought Pierce was in a
yellow dress there today Donald Trump
that's what we're coming to though he
boarded his private jet he's flying
currently from Florida to New York he's
the first American president to be
impeached twice heading to court now to
be the first American President to face
criminal charges now is this over
January 6th no is it over the classified
documents found at Mar-A-Lago no is it
over the 2020 election in Georgia he
tried to overturn that defeat no legal
fights in all of those cases are still
ongoing this is over that 130 thousand
dollar hush money payment Trump made to
porn star Stormy Daniels during his 2016
election campaign so does this mean his
presidential bid is over no quite
frankly in fact quite probably the
opposite it likely means his re-election
campaign is really getting underwear and
Earnest now his team raked in over five
million dollars in the 48 hours after
his indictment was announced over the
weekend and now this is the Staggering
pot this really stood out to me over 25
of those donations came from first time
supporters to Donald Trump now if
there's one thing we know about the
Donald is that he knows how to work a
circus and what he is calling a
politically motivated Witch Hunt against
him by a Democrat district attorney and
a Democrat State and one of let's call
it the most bizarre offenses in his War
chest it's only galvanizing Trump's base
more and it's attracting new fans and
guess what he can constitutionally still
run for president in 2024 even if he's
sitting in prison now the courts have a
service to justice of course we'll get
more details of the precise charges
against Trump tomorrow in that Court
remember that we don't really even have
the detail yet a lot of people are
already jumping to conclusions here but
the question politically is this is this
the right approach for or anyone who is
indeed seeking to keep Trump out of
power well for the results of the
weekend the donations and the support
seemingly not so if it is a quote
politically motivated Witch Hunt that
gotta hurt joining me now to discuss all
this author and commentator Bonnie Greer
you could see you're nodding along to
some of that we'll come to you and
conservative radio host Ben Ferguson
don't know if you were nodding along Ben
but we will uh we will shortly find out
Ben let's start with you then I mean in
all of this a crime is a crime right of
course a crime has got to be tried in
court
well look the problem is there's not a
crime that's committed here and it's
going to end up being thrown out this is
the dumbest case I've ever seen brought
especially against the former president
there's a reason why Federal prosecutors
did not prosecute this same crime when
it was before them the the former
district attorney in New York also in an
interview this morning said he did not
bring this crime against Donald Trump
when he had four years to do it because
he said he believed it was a ridiculous
charge and that was a liberal Democrat
who said that as well this activist D.A
Alvin Bragg has overstepped here
Democrats were begging him in the final
hours to not do this some of the biggest
allies of Barack Obama were saying
publicly on TV he's overstepping he
needs to walk back from the brink so you
just gave the biggest in-kind donation I
think in political history with this
indictment to Donald Trump you're
rallying troops behind him a lot of
people that didn't like Donald Trump by
the way are are giving him money which
you just mentioned in historic numbers
so I think this might be the biggest
backfire in political history as well
well let's see if we can tip out the
scales then with Bonnie here in the
studio Bonnie let's talk about some of
what Ben mentioned then by just
discussing this by just talking about
the figures from the weekend are we
emboldening Trump's campaign well you
can't embolden Donald Trump any more
than he's born to be this is how this
guy rolls and I'm saying as a former New
Yorker I mean Donald Trump's been in the
fire for you know 30 40 50 years they've
even got a headline on the New York
Times there was in the 70s about the
trouble he was in so Donald has kind of
been in this water for a long time and
Ben is right you know courses is going
to Galvanize his followers anything with
Galvanize his followers so you know if
he ate a ham sandwich in front of you
know whatever that would Galvanize them
so that's not the issue it's also if the
Republican party is crazy enough to
actually run him which would be super
hope he's going to get beaten again see
the thing is this and I think that that
what's overlooked
the United States is a country of laws
not men I don't know who said that but
that is a quote the district attorney is
an elected official and the district
attorney determines within his or her
District what the law is the feds don't
get involved and people from the outside
don't get involved now this case will
fall or rise tomorrow in the court when
the judge decides whether it's worth it
and the other thing we need to remember
is this indictment was brought by
ordinary Americans not by the district
attorney it's brought by the grand jury
so he brings the case they decide and
then the judge says okay I like it or I
don't that's it and that was a point I
wanted to bring up with uh Ben so thanks
for explaining that especially to our
British viewers and our other
International viewers how the US justice
system works because as Bonnie brightly
pointed out that it's a grand jury it's
a pair of normal people in this court uh
Ben the district attorney democratically
nominated yes but if you are saying as
many sort of Transporters or gosp
supporters are that it's a politically
motivated Witch Hunt and it's a sham
trial and not my words but the words are
plenty of supporters out there is that
not saying there's something wrong with
the U.S justice system
no because look grand juries are very
much uh not connected to the back story
on these types of indictments I'll give
you a great example the grand jury
doesn't know that the federal government
refused to prosecute and said there was
no crime here the grand jury also
doesn't know that they are turning a
misdemeanor into a felony that's the
problem with this case you can get
indictments and there are there are
countless hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of indictments that have been
thrown out immediately and or on appeal
you are in a very limited box when
you're on a grand jury and your job is
to look at what they put in front of you
you have an activist D.A that's
selectively giving you information you
don't understand the back story here you
don't understand the FED said there's no
crime here you don't know that the
former D.A said there's no crime here
and you don't know all of these things
so when he comes in and he says to you
here is my case they may not even
realize that he has created out of thin
there a felony that doesn't exist this
will be thrown out mark my word it will
be thrown out and that's where this D.A
is going to have egg on his face Ben we
don't know the details of uh the exact
challenges yet of course we'll have to
wait for that and he's our business
audio given Ben's also given the beauty
of the grand jury system they aren't a
bunch of lawyers they aren't people who
went to Harvard lawyer law they aren't
politicians they aren't political
commentators they're Joe Blow and his
wife from the street and they decided
that this needed to go to a judge the
judge then decides no this isn't this he
might throw it out tomorrow that's his
job good job of the people Ben let me
finish the job of the people is
determine what it looks like to them now
again it could be thrown out Trump is
innocent until proven guilty and that's
the end of this story until he's until
the judge rules if he rules tomorrow Ben
it's not the end of story because this
political harassment has been going on
since 2016. and by the way Hillary
Clinton if you're going to claim that
Donald Trump has committed this crime uh
what I'm saying I'm saying that I'm
saying the prosecutor I'm saying the
prosecutor all right let me care Alvin
Bragg is saying that Donald Trump took
money and he said it was legal fees when
it actually wasn't and it was a hush
payment if that is true then you would
have to go back and charge Hillary
Clinton for the exact same crime in the
exact same year in the exact same place
New York City she had the steel dossier
there's no shaking the head here this is
the fact no I am shaking yeah
let me finish hold on let me just finish
because people need to understand this
around the world Hillary Clinton paid
for the still dossier they they labeled
that in her campaign Finance report as
legal Feast she was found guilty of
doing that wrong and the FCC forced her
and the Democratic National Committee to
pay a fine and even then a D.A did not
say that she should be charged Criminal
of the day
this is not some kind of thing in the
back in the day of the day
this is an ancient history make this is
today now somebody wants to come up and
if somebody wants to come up and charge
Hillary Clinton well fine nobody's done
it let's bring it back I'm not doing it
because this is political political and
they're going after Donald Trump because
they hate him Hillary Clinton 2
six years ago too late Ben I'm not
trying to gloss over history I see the
point you're making but let's bring it
to the present day let's bring it back
to Donald Trump that list that we read
out at the beginning of the show uh
January 6 Georgia 2020 uh the dossier of
documents at Mar-A-Lago when you look at
all that in sort of entirety isn't it
the case the American people deserve a
bit better on the behavior standards
I think they deserve better from
activists what prosecutors have been put
in by George Soros who are trying to
take out their political opponents the
leader of the Republican party and
that's been their Obsession since 2016.
I also think this is a dangerous
precedent let me explain why are you
seriously we are doing this let me
finish the fact that we are doing this
and I don't believe that anyone by the
way should charge Hillary Clinton with a
crime that we talked about earlier I
think you don't charge people like this
because you don't like them I don't
think you weaponize like a third world
country and Communists and dictators and
tyrants the Judicial Systems
where does George what the hell does
that mean wait a minute how does George
Soros get into this
George Soros back Alvin Brad you should
know that he was the top donor to Alvin
Williams
songs
side of things because it does get very
toxic that side of the debate but I just
want to ask them uh ask Bonnie then is
it
is it a politically motivated Witch Hunt
can you see a little bit of what Ben is
saying they're given that this is a
Democrat State there's a Democrat D.A in
charge could you are you able to bend to
that position no and I I'm going to say
this to Ben because he's got the same
name let me let me speak sir because
he's got the same let me speak let me
speak please
I will give this to Ben okay
a D.A is elected and runs on a platform
and Alvin Bragg made no bones about
wanting to get Donald Trump okay
so in that sense in quotes every D.A is
politically motivated the deal is you
take hang on the deal is you take it to
the Grand Jury the grand jury says yep
or no if the grand jury says yes it goes
to the judge then the judge says I like
this or it's I'm throwing it out end of
and that's how it works in the United
States Ben yeah I mean you either
believe in your own justice system or
you don't if you begin to pick away at
these institutions of democracy I
believe in the justice system but I also
think they're bad actors in every sector
of Life we've had bad actors that are
priests we've had bad actors or teachers
we've had bad actors in law enforcement
well Republicans
no matter what no I said in every sector
Bonnie I said in every sector okay and
I'll go back to what I was saying a
moment ago Alvin Bragg ran and this is
going to be the problem when he gets up
into the higher courts on appeal and
this is going to fall apart he ran and
he was on the record hell he was doing
TV interviews the week he was indicting
Donald Trump he's a partisan guy who
said vote for me and I'll now Trump you
show me Donald Trump and I will find you
a crime and by the way he's wanting to
run for governor this is all political
things I hear what I said before it met
Alvin Bragg has to take it to the Grand
Jury he doesn't bring it up and we
already talked about the grand jury the
grand jury has a very limited scope of
understanding
because if you're complaining about the
grand jury which is what you're doing
then you don't I'm talking about the
real
[Music]
how a grand jury works and the fact is
when this goes to a judge and they see
the bias of Alvin Brown and they see
that he created charges out of thin air
that are not felonies out of a
misdemeanor that has already reached its
statute of limitations it will be thrown
out and you guys are gonna you might be
right you might be right you might be
right
but don't knock the grand jury system
there we go I'm saying the United States
of America this has been fascinating to
listen to to find out more about the
system Ben Ferguson Bonnie gray thank
you both for your insights your input
we're just getting started Trump hasn't
even landed in New York now coming up
next tonight the new BBC adaptation of
Great Expectations probably make Charles
Dickens blush with its scenes of sex and
Drug taking what was wrong with the
original why can't modern writers just
leave the classics alone we'll be
finding out next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back to the show next
tonight if you were expecting Sunday
night last night to sit down enjoy some
wholesome family entertainment with the
BBC's latest adaptation of Charles
Dickens classic great expectations well
you might have thought again the period
drama was instead turned into a
sexualized fantasy with the sight of Mr
pumblechook being spanked by a housewife
turned dominatrix Mrs Gregory enough to
make Dickens turn in his grave we were
wondering whether we should put a
trigger warning even before that Spanky
But the irony of that now just the
latest in a wave of so-called work
reimaginings Gone With the Wind set
during the American Civil War it now
contains a trigger warning for racism
James Bond books have been Rewritten to
remove offensive references and Roald
Dahl's children's Classics have of
course also been altered to drop words
like ugly and fat so we're asking this
evening is it time we just left those
classics alone police say Bonnie Grace
still joining me here in the studio he
had a good warm up right with Ben yeah
and also joined down the line by
columnist Jamel on Sunday Peter Hitchens
who's written a fascinating piece on
this in the mail online do go and have a
look at that as well we're going to get
the inside scoop now from Peter Peter
lay out your case to us about great
expectations didn't live up to your
expectations
well Great Expectations is one of the
greatest books ever written uh beyond
that one about two or three and it lives
in the imaginations of those who've read
it uh it's all that imagination is
fortified by the tremendously good film
of it made but shortly after the second
world war by David Lee again probably
one of the greatest films I've made and
so there it is in our imagination which
is where books live they're not like
sculptures or buildings which have a
solid form which can't be changed or
even like music which must be played
more or less in the same way depending
on the conductor they exist say in our
imaginations and people like me object
very strongly to having our imaginations
conveyed in by people who don't seem to
care very much about the book I don't
mind if people want to write and produce
and televised dramas about spanking
smoking and swearing and all the other
things which go on in this rather drab
series that's fine by me but they don't
have to call it great expectations or to
give it that
also always pretend which is maybe is
what they're doing but they're in any
way televising or dramatizing great
expectations it's something completely
different he wants to call it something
else as far as I'm concerned that I
weren't mine but if he says it's great
expectations then I'm going to object
and I'm going to get quite strongly that
this absolutely extraordinary
astonishing and heartbreaking
to people who've previously never
experienced it and I think that's a very
great shape so it's not a matter of
taste per se or the spanking that's the
issue for you but it's that
associated with the sticky Dickens novel
because anybody will put that Dickens
contain all human life and many things
which happen in his books it can be
extremely ugly and as I don't know which
right he pointed out the other day uh in
a very interesting blog which I
recommend the portrayal of Fagan
as it as a classical anti-semite side
here of a Jew and all of the twitch and
then the film of it is something which
is almost impossible to defend it wasn't
perfect and a number of the things which
he wrote about were deeply unpleasant so
I'm not I'm not objecting to these
things because they're unpleasant I'm
objecting to them because they're not
true to the book the book itself is
quite powerful and frightening and
distressing enough uh without people
putting in these modern preoccupations
and without them
turning the characters in the story of
something completely different when I
look at the past I look at the past as a
point of Records to see whether we're
doing as well or better or worse than we
than we were well I think the makers of
this version of the interpretations
look at the past they they see something
to be looked down upon and despised
because everything that goes on in the
modern world is better I think they have
that the wrong way right
uh Bonnie let's let's bring you in on
this then is it a a case of poetic
license too far well I'm not you know I
I don't completely disagree with Peter
Hitchens on this I mean and one of the
reasons I don't is because I'm you know
I'm a baby boomer okay I'm a boomer I
don't know if Peter Hitchens is but we
were brought up on the classics we were
brought up on that great sort of Western
Canon so you read Dickens if you didn't
read Dickens or didn't know how to read
Dickens you were taught Dickens I also
agree with Peter Hitchens about the
David lean film which is a masterpiece
but he knows as well as I do that the uh
the Betrayal I mean not in that film but
the Betrayal of fagin
um in in one of the other films actually
got it almost banned in the United
States so there people have always done
this people have always changed things
to fit the taste of the time and and and
Classics have always sort of been
manipulated I mean uh I used to teach
Shakespeare in this country uh to people
in the inner city and of course you
can't do it straight because they can't
actually take it in so you you make it
so that they can and then they enter the
verse that way they enter it in that way
and it's quite a beautiful process and
the classics are always sort of
manipulated in a sense I I think
um first of all this is business
um BBC One cannot exist on attracting
the likes of Peter and me it's not just
not going to be there okay so it's got
to actually decide what it's going to do
this writer the the author of peaky
blinders is a very successful writer he
has got a following so how do you
re-translate this book so that people
they'll look at the program and then
maybe they might read the book but
that's not the BBC's obligation the
BBC's obligation is for you to look at
the program and and people are doing it
now you know the question is uh is this
going to harm Dickens that's the
question I don't think so I think the
general rational point you bring up is
particularly interesting I'm a
millennial firmly in a millennial
bracket I actually did an English
literature degree at University so I've
got the classics I got them down pat and
when I think about this and BBC making
this adaptation to be honest I don't
really care I I don't I don't have to
watch it if I don't want to and let me
tell you something else Jen said would
not watch it unless it was like this so
these are all the different sort of
categories it is but then let's bring
pizza back in then Peter the point that
Bonnie made there which I think is also
Salient about sort of respecting Dickens
and his his Mastery and it's the point
you were making too then does that bring
an argument in almost for sort of
Regulation you know making sure that the
classics can't be touched
no I I wouldn't want that I think this
is a matter of what I'm doing Isis you
know somebody who has some small role in
between reunite pictures apologies
people come back to you of Donald Trump
a former president United States this is
his plan his private plane of course
Landing in New York it has been in the
air since Mar alago today Bonnie is
booging next to me on the desk I've got
to tell you that much uh shortly going
to be touching our wheels on tarmac he's
going to be heading I believe to Trump
Tower in Manhattan tonight where he's
going to have a cozy night in his own
bed before heading of course the
courthouse in Manhattan tomorrow where
he is going to face this indictment in
front of a judge in front of a grand
jury on these charges that are 130 000
hush payment was made to Pawn Stars
Stormy Daniels this was during the time
of his 2016 presidential election
campaign of course we have heard from
sources speaking to certain news
networks that there may be as much as 30
plus charges contained with this in this
and die treatment nobody actually really
knows yet until we see the details
tomorrow here we go we just want to show
you this moment the wheels landing on
tarmac Bonnie really is enjoying herself
here in the studio is it just that you
enjoy seeing Donald Trump back in his
spiritual homeland of New York Bonnie
you know Donald Trump was made by New
York he's a quintessential if you can't
make it there you can't make it anywhere
I mean this guy is from Queens and he's
always one I'm a former New Yorker so
I'm telling you he was always wanted to
be in Manhattan the tabloids made him
all of that made him he's back and look
how he's back so it's fabulous actually
I can't even tell you
fabulous in different ways I'm sure in
your mind I just want to go back to
Peter because we so rudely interrupted
him for former president Donald Trump
The Landing at the time at Peter
apologized for that was asking you about
whether or not we should almost bring in
regulation to protect the classics to
protect the great writers of course not
and they have to defend themselves and
it's and we have to defend them those
who love them and believe them to be
valuable have to defend them against The
Barbarians who want to water them down
change and turn them into something else
I think it would be a terrible terrible
shame if people grew up in this country
thinking that this peaky blinders
version of great hip rotations was the
real thing and this is the great danger
that it will overlay the the older the
book and the David Lee film and we'll
displace it and so I think therefore for
people like me it is a simple Duty we
stand up and say this is wrong we
shouldn't do this leave it alone if you
want to make your do you think you're
spanking and the rest do it but don't
call it my expectations
Bonnie do you think people are fooled
that it's the real thing no and and can
I say that one of the most moving
experiences I ever had was when I was
teaching Shakespeare to kids who
wouldn't touch it and uh this was a
classroom full of boys tearaways
I got them to settle down I did my
technique then I gave them the first
Soliloquy and I said just read it
you know I would defy anybody for the
world Shakespeare Theater or anybody to
beat what those guys did because they
went into that text and when you invite
people in ways they understand and you
put the text down in front of them
nobody's going to destroy Charles
Dickens it ain't gonna happen but if
there's a way that a door can be opened
and it can be opened with a good teacher
then he gets bigger and bigger and
bigger I mean some of the themes of
Shakespeare Alive and Well today in
Manhattan one could argue we've got
tragedy we've got the works uh Bonnie
Greer Peter Hitchens there speaking to
us about the classics about Great
Expectations thanks to both of you
coming up next the American Farmer
condemned by vegan activists for letting
people hug his goats is it animal
cruelty as they claim will be debating
that after the break
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no what are you every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the show well first they
came to your Sunday roasts then they
came a few Percy pigs now these pesky
vegan activists want to ban you from
hugging animals apparently this Farm in
Pennsylvania has been forced to abandon
its regular hugger goat event because
local animal rights Crusaders can't
stomach the idea of goat cuddles being
pimped out for profit but here's the
thing this Farm doesn't kill the animals
they say they aren't Mass farming goats
on an industrial scale to supply
supermarkets and they say it's a passion
project the money they're raising from
these goat cuddles going towards
building a better Barn for the goats
let's get some more on this story I feel
there's a bit more to this joined Now by
Justin Steinmetz owner of the family
farm joining us with a goat on his lap
as well we'll come back to you very
shortly I want to introduce Cheryl
Petrillo as well from the Rights group
animal Defenders Cheryl thanks also for
joining us uh also with me in the studio
talk TV contributor Esther kraku and
Jeremy corbyn's former advisor one them
James Schneider so we're gonna have a
lot of views on this but first let's get
back out to that goat shell we set on
Jason's lap that's the only thing we
really care about here James Rather
sorry uh Jason
it's Justin does he have a name Dustin
Justin is my name Justin
apologies I thought I was asking for the
goat's name
the
floppy and frit floppy and Brit this is
uh it's lovely to see you there uh with
the goats this is the type of service
you were offering walk us through it
what was your plan here what have you
been doing with the goats and why have
you run into trouble
uh we've just been doing goat snuggling
uh since last July and always been well
until uh we got some slack from some
animal rights activists and you know
things things kind of went a little bit
south from there
when you say went South what what impact
has it had on you
uh we've been you know had to
remove ourselves from some local events
and they've also removed Us by
complaining to the event coordinators of
the uh of the actual events for one of
them so basically uh we just had to step
away from some events that would have
brought in some income for the farm
okay so that's had I had some impact on
you obviously this has gone in some
headlines otherwise we wouldn't have
been speaking to you about it so let's
also bring in Cheryl and talk to her a
little bit about this Cheryl give us
your outline on why you've objected to
what is happening at Justin's Farm
hey first I want to say thank you for
having me on um this is a huge surprise
so never in my wildest dreams what I
imagine I'd be sitting here
um talking about this or with you so
nice to meet you
um so yes
um so I'm a president of a vegan
organization here in the Lehigh Valley
Pennsylvania
and uh they're the couple vegan or
plant-based events that were coming to
our area and we're very excited to be
tabling at that
and um you know when the list of the
vendors came out we saw one that had one
about a farm so of course we're very
curious so we we did our research and
much to our dismay
um
I I see that the majority uh of their
work is breeding selling and renting
animals
um um Cheryl yeah I have to agree with
you I never thought I'd be here talking
about this either but I want to pose
that uh to Justin Justin
um would you want to counter that that
you're actually breeding and selling
these animals as well uh you are a
farmer I suppose but is it more than
just goat cuddles
um we are farmers
um so we we obviously use our animals to
make our income and our livelihood
that's what we do
um we do have some breeding stock as
well as we rescue some animals for
example
um
the floppy that was in my lap earlier is
a rescue this is floppy and this guy
this one here is Brit she was born on
our farm so yeah we do we do breed uh
some of the animals and we do
um rescue some of the animals and we
provide entertainment and we provide a
good time for people that come and
snuggle the goats as well as therapy
they actually have an emotional support
goat officially licensed for
basically emotional support so yeah we
we do all those things that they claim
we do
Cheryl I'm looking at these pictures um
while we're listening to Justice of the
goats sort of being played with and
cuddled and you know I have a couple of
pets myself and I cuddle them and I
doesn't really feel like cruelty to me
am I just missing something obvious here
no no I mean I will say anytime that an
animal is being used
um for whatever reason though it's
potential for for harm or something not
good to happen looking at these pictures
yes they look like it looks like happy
people and uh potentially a very happy
goat not sure the issue that we have
with the event that we did not want them
to be present at our event including the
transportation of the animals which can
be very stressful bringing 40 I don't
I'm not sure how many goats Justin
brings but I think it's a considerable
number
um we were cons always concerned about
that
and you know that basically his business
doesn't align with vegan value so that
was really why we reached out to the
event organizer and asked them to
reconsider and we did offer them other
alternative of sanctuary that would
align more with what veganism is about
well okay let's see if we can find some
sort of resolution some reconciliation
on the show tonight then because you're
offering some compromise you said you
already reached out to the stymeters
about this Justin talk to us about that
did you see these compromises did you
consider them or is it a case of you
need to make money because you run a
farm
exactly
um there was no compromise other than I
did bow out of the events so I didn't I
didn't want to create uh I didn't want
to create an opportunity for them to
pick it like they've done like the
extremists do I will tell you that the
um
a lot of the uh people that were going
to attend that event uh or both of those
events were very upset that we weren't
going to be there including vegans
themselves uh I don't have a problem
with vegans I just have a problem with
the vegan extremists that really want to
put us down uh their group uh their
group called the animal Defenders of
Lehigh Valley
uh they
put out some information that was
completely false that originally stating
that all of our goats go to slaughter
when they're done that we artificially
inseminate and force breed
um and that it's just a lot of false
information so they didn't have it
correct
um so I I don't I'm not going to change
their mind I understand uh so that's
basically that's basically how it rolls
around here we're just gonna continue
doing what we do
um and provide an awesome experience for
people
um veganism is a choice being a vegan is
a choice and so is being a farmer so I'm
gonna continue to do what I do and
hopefully we can you know find some sort
of happy medium here without everyone
getting up in arms and upset that we do
what we do and I don't try to force my
beliefs upon them I simply you know just
doing what we do she said let's give
share a chance to respond to that at
those allegations Cheryl that you
Prince Farm which could have been quite
damaging to him but he's saying he can
still coexist alongside you
oh I don't know if it's a really false
information so on a whole I mean you
know selling goats
you know most likely I mean whether he
somebody goes go to a truly adoptable
home or they'll live permanently
um that may be the case but I've worked
at a number of sanctuaries myself with
goats and I've gone to auction houses
um in Pennsylvania New Jersey and and
there are goats
typically go to auction also known as
eventually Slaughter after they're done
being used whether it's a dairy goat who
can't make milk anymore whether at the
rental goat who's not cute and tiny
anymore and maybe doesn't serve a
purpose on the farm and won't make money
I mean it makes sense Farmers can't keep
animals that they can't use anymore so
where do they go if we could if there
was exactly are goats strictly go to
other homesteads other farms in fact
every one of our sales of our goats when
they're too big to snuggle we have
record of where they're at and we
actually linked them to our Facebook
page so our followers can follow the
history and the story of where all the
goats go and they go there and they get
to visit the goats on other Farms not
one of our goats have gone to auction
not one of our goats have gone to
slaughter
we have proof in records of where they
all go so
again a false statement about where our
goats end up that you've both had an
opportunity to lay out your positions it
sounds like there is some level of
Harmony where you both are uh it's been
a pleasure talking to you both Cheryl
Petrillo and Justin steinbetz and uh
floppy the goat thanks ever so much for
joining us all three of you next tonight
here on the show Labor's secure Starman
becomes the latest leader to get stuck
into the thorny issue of what exactly a
woman is I'll see if we can sort that
out after the break
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel don't worry
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
please
coming up on the talk the panel reacts
to the 42-year sentence handed to gunman
Thomas Cashman who killed nine-year-olds
Olivia Pratt Corbell at her home in
Liverpool and teachers in England set
out more days of strike action as exam
season looms and is 8 million pounds of
taxpayers cash spent on portraits of
King Charles a valid expense during a
cost of living crisis all of that coming
up at nine
[Music]
welcome back fears Morgan uncensored
Rosanna Lockwood that's me in for peers
next couple of days while he takes a
well-earned break now let's get to
Esther and James they're still with us
here in the studio you were listening to
uh the goat's reconciliation piece we
just did uh your initial thoughts on
that before we tackle some more serious
matters what a wonderful weird diverse
world we live in I mean and and I think
they were both goat lovers really so
they could have they could have come
together in um and cuddled the goats to
I might I don't know really but
interesting and fun some of us love good
others love curry goat so it's a
wonderful and diverse world that we live
in I'm certainly on the latter side of
things but look I wish I had those kinds
of problems in the world where I'm
concerned with the well-being of goats I
would recommend they don't go to a Greek
Easter because I think both of them
might be traumatized and Beyond repair
uh
in the country I do care about the
welfare of animals but I do enjoy eating
eating um yes occasionally as well so
you know I can't but cuddling a goat
does look quite enjoyable let's let's
get to some more serious topics at hand
we have of course Scott you're in James
as a former advisor to Jeremy corbyn
representing something of the Left End
of the spectrum and that's what I want
to come to you first because we did talk
to viewers before the break about this
story over the weekend to Ikea stalma of
course the opposition labor leader in
some hot water over what a woman is now
we had these comments from him over the
weekend this was in the Sunday Times I
believe it was where he said yeah around
99.9 of women are biological uh female
are women
um of course when you take that headline
out starkly and say yeah and around 99.9
of women do not have a penis
um it grabbed headlines and I think it's
fair to say it's understandable why
because as a woman I sort of really go
well 100 of women don't have a penis but
of course we understand what we're
talking about here we're talking about
trans rights
um there is a little bit of nuance to
this of course but stalma has found
himself struggling with this over the
years let's hear what he uh said in
previous months
Nick I'm not but
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
no no
I just a woman can't have a penis I
don't think that
um discussing this issue in this way
helps anyone
so I think what we're seeing here is a
bit of a pivot a bit of a policy shift
here you speak some sort of they've said
storm and the labor party need to get on
board with a women's rights message
because the labor party have struggled
when it comes to getting female support
According to some sources James do you
think that's fair
uh no I don't really think that's fair
the polling doesn't suggest that women
aren't supporting labor and this is a
very very uh Fringe issue that isn't at
the Forefront of most people's concerns
Minds most people regardless of how kind
of flanned up headlines are most people
in the country are broadly in the same
position which is what you outlined
pretty much in your introduction which
is
basically or you know biological women
obviously don't have penises there's a
tiny minority of people that were not
born as biological women who are trans
women who become women and really it
shouldn't be bothering us terribly at
all now kirst armor isn't very good at
talking about it but and he's not very
consistent at it but then kirstama is
not very good at talking about a lot of
things that he's not very consistent on
really anything but that's by the by
that's the issue itself it isn't this
big dramatic thing that it gets
presented in uh in the medium really a
lot of the time I think it is uh it's
sort of used as a distraction from
talking about other issues because
basically most people uh agree they're
quite sensitive about the fact that
there's this very marginal group of in
society very very small but um uh that
are different from most you know most
people the overwhelming majority of
people their sex is their gender for a
tiny number of people that is in the
case and really it's not such a big deal
as we're just saying there's a rich
diversity in human existence since and
you know that's that's one of them and
maybe for some people it's it's a bit
jarring a bit different but many things
are but it's it's it is the case that
leaders are increasingly finding
themselves tied up in knots when it
comes to this maybe they don't have the
the luxury of having a few minutes to
explain it um as you just did there and
they you see that 99.9 headline and it
grabs people's attention there so let's
before we come to you let's just remind
ourselves it was the undoing really of
Nicholas sturgeon
my question is are all trans women women
they haven't answered that question well
that's not the point that we're dealing
with the question trans women are women
but in the present context there is no
automatic right for a trans woman in our
context where a trans woman is not a
woman no there is
circumstances in which a trans woman
will be housed in the male prison estate
so Esther I mean how should politicians
how should leaders be framing this
debate so that they the public
understand that they understand that
it's a nuanced issue but also that they
understand that women are women I mean I
remember Rosie Duffield coming on here a
few months ago talking about what her
impression of kirstama's view of this
issue was and he made it very clear that
he does believe it's a fringe issue and
that not many people are concerned but
for some reason we see it coming up
again and again in the headlines because
you have issues like Isla Bryson who was
in a you know female prison even though
this is clearly a male rapist right you
do have these you know spectacularly
unique issues of you know women uh or
trans women and women's sports that are
clearly lives and Bounds ahead of the
competition so the question is why
doesn't this go away and it's because
the the half of the population women who
are predominantly affected by these
issues because if you don't draw a line
in the sand then really the public
policy moves to actually if you are if
you identify as a woman and public
policy reflects that you can be in
women's shelters for instance or in
women's prisons and that does that does
impact you know women in general and I I
understand why it's you know it seemed
like a fringe issue and most people find
it difficult to see but actually when
you are a woman and you are in that that
kind of um those that those spaces or
those circumstances it actually becomes
quite an uncomfortable experience I mean
listen I've said that we need some
proportionality in how we talk about
these issues because there are about 10
trans people in the UK and so we
shouldn't always make it you know a big
issue as if they're always trying to try
and force their way into spaces and all
of that but there is a small minority
that do make women feel uncomfortable in
the sense of what spaces they can use
right and that's something that
politicians need to be able to draw a
line in the Sun and say actually when I
am in power your rights won't be rolled
back and it's weird because you think
they're more they're bigger issues as
the cost of living crisis and all of
that but we want to be reassured that if
Kirsten was to become the next prime
minister of England you're not going to
have a situation where Isla Bryson's in
the UK can find their way into women's
spaces and that's why we have to keep
reiterating it I'm sick of hearing
people asking politicians what a woman
is but I understand why some women feel
so passionate about myself included and
so I don't think it's just you know what
kisama thought it was originally which
is a fringe issue I think that is
something that would really hold him
back and I think he's been
underestimating it for far too long uh
fascinating stuff will continue to see
them picking over this uh topic I'm sure
in the lead up to the election but
before we go we do want to bring you
this importance story last week of
course Wall Street Journal reporter Evan
gershkovich was arrested in Russia the
Kremlin uh he they claimed the
experienced journalist is a spy for the
US government now the Wall Street
Journal whoever works for they strongly
deny this they are calling it a hostage
taking and we just wanted to talk to you
about it because of course it is a start
reminder of the risks that journalists
take every day doing their jobs to bring
you the truth we too at this channel
condemn Evan gershkovich's detention we
call for him to be released immediately
and we just want to speak to you too
both about this as well what were your
reactions James I continue noddling
along there uh yes I I there are
hundreds of journalists that are
imprisoned around the world who should
be immediately freed including Julian
Assange who's in prison here in London
who's probably the most significant
journalist of the last 20 years who's
being held for four years in belmarsh
prison to be sent off to the U.S to face
life imprisonment there for the crime of
doing journalism of course that is a
hotly debated topic we don't have time
to debate it today but would love to
speak to you again about that at another
point because I think it is a recent
debate to be had about Junior science
and where that Stacks up against this
case Esther what did you think when you
read about Evan I mean I I was extremely
disappointing obviously but it's not
surprising giving the Russian regime's
track record in in well lack thereof
political freedoms
um but I I I do think it's a stock of
Mind of actually how how important
journalists are I mean in the last few
years it's become kind of fashionable to
beat on the media and journalists and
you know trying to find true journalism
through journalists and journalism and
you know they're not doing their jobs
properly but I actually think it's a far
more nuanced and complicated issue and
then people really risking their lives
on the front line like this individual
was and to try and get information out
there and I think we have to remember
that thank you both James a lot of
topics this evening that is it from me
for today I'll be back here tomorrow
info peers again whatever you're up to
tonight make sure it is uncensored
thanks so much for joining us
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she